it all began last year when a handful of
students with apparently too much time
on their hands circulated a petition
demanding that the colonial mascot be
removed and replaced they wrote this is
from the petition the use of Colonials
no matter how innocent the intention is
received as extremely offensive not only
by students of the university but by the
nation and the world at large the
petition went on the historically
negatively-charged figure of Colonials
has too deep a connection to
colonisation and they said this of jorge
de colonial big mascot glorifies the act
of systemic oppression now the moment
that I read this position their petition
rather I knew one thing I knew one thing
for certain this had to be written by
white liberals I knew it I knew because
the way you know the language you would
make it seem like it was written by
somebody who is a recent immigrant or
the child of some oppressed group but I
knew it wasn't the only thing I knew for
sure from that language is that it was
white liberals and then I googled it and
it would appear that I'm correct I don't
want to make assumptions I don't I don't
know the students but it would appear to
be the case that I'm right how did I
know that because this sort of activism
is always the product of white liberals
pretending to be offended on behalf of
other people it's never Native Americans
who are clamoring to change the name of
the Washington Redskins or the Cleveland
Indians it is always white liberals
pretending to be offended on their
behalf it must be nice do these white
liberals have jobs do they have anything
to do do they have any problems of their
own I wonder this is the best evidence
that I have ever found for white
privilege is the fact that white
liberals pull these stunts all the time
if you have so much time and emotional
energy that you are spending all of it
pretending to be offended on other
people's behalf you have privilege the
petition got 514 signatures
so this means it's a big school but you
know they got 514 so it was taken up for
a vote and the student body voted on
whether or not to remove colonial as the
mascot the measure passed this past
March that is the bad news the good news
is it passed by a pretty slim margin
just 54 percent of the students who
voted voted to get rid of poor ol George
to colonial the detailed numbers are
more revealing because only 5,000
students actually participated in the
vote now the school has about 12,000
undergrads and about 25,000 or 26,000
students total so if you look at the
percentage overall as a percentage of
the undergraduate population only 42% of
people voted and only 23% voted to
remove the mascot if you look at this as
a percentage of the total university
population then just 20% voted and only
11% voted to remove the colonial those
numbers are about what I would expect
because if you want to pretend that
George the colonial is offensive
you will be highly motivated to vote on
this issue if you are a normal person
you will not be motivated to to waste
your time on this ridiculous non
traversée